Hemos hablado sobre la configuración
electrónica en muchos videos. Ahora,
en este video vamos a ampliar esa comprensión al
pensar en la configuración electrónica de iones,
éstos serán átomos cargados. Comencemos con
algunos ejemplos. Digamos que estamos tratando con
flúor. Ahora, sabemos cuál sería la configuración
electrónica de un átomo neutro de flúor, de hecho,
si quieres tener un poco de práctica pausa
el video y piensa ¿cuál es la configuración
electrónica de un átomo neutro de flúor? Muy bien,
ahora trabajemos juntos. Un átomo neutro de flúor
tiene 9 electrones. Podemos usar nuestra tabla
periódica de elementos. Primero vamos a tener 2
electrones en 1s, así que tenemos 1s², y luego
vamos a la segunda capa, vamos a 2s². Hasta
aquí llevamos 4 electrones, luego llegamos a la
subcapa 2p. Estamos hablando de un flúor neutro,
así que vamos a tener 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 electrones
en la subcapa 2p, de modo que tenemos 2p⁵.
Si esa es la configuración electrónica para el
flúor, ¿cuál crees que sería la configuración
electrónica de ion fluoruro? Este es sólo el
anión que tiene 1 electrón extra, es un ion
cargado negativamente. Pausa este video y trata de
resolverlo. Bueno, aquí vamos a tener 1 electrón
extra, el flúor ha atrapado 1 electrón de algún
lugar, ¿y a dónde irá ese electrón extra? Bueno,
nuestra subcapa 2p tiene espacio para un
electrón más, así que es ahí donde irá,
de modo que el anión fluoruro va a tener una
configuración electrónica de 1s², 2s², 2p ahora va
a tener un electrón extra aquí, 2p⁶. Ahora hagamos
otro ejemplo. Digamos que queremos descubrir la
configuración electrónica de un ion calcio con
carga positiva parcial, así que escribamos Ca²⁺,
tiene una carga positiva de 2. Podríamos ver esto
como un calcio neutro que ha perdido 2 electrones,
¿cuál será su configuración electrónica?
Pausa este video y trata de resolverlo.
Muy bien, una forma de resolver esto es descubrir
primero la configuración electrónica de un átomo
de calcio neutro y luego podemos quitar dos
de los electrones de mayor energía. Así que
calcio neutral, hagámoslo en configuración de gas
noble: calcio neutro, el gas noble que está justo
antes del calcio es el argón, así que tenemos
la configuración electrónica del argón, y luego
vamos a tener dos electrones para esa cuarta capa,
vamos a completar la subcapa 4s. Entonces vamos a
tener argón y luego 4s². Ahora, ¿qué crees que
pasaría si perdiéramos dos electrones? Bueno,
estos dos electrones en la subcapa 4 se van a
ir, así que la configuración electrónica para
calcio con dos cargas positivas, este catión
calcio va a ser la configuración electrónica
del argón y quitamos 4s², así que en realidad
va a tener exactamente la misma configuración
electrónica que el argón. Así lo voy a dejar,
sólo con un par de ejemplos. Y te animo a que
elijas cualquiera de estos átomos, cualquiera de
estos elementos, y pienses en lo que sucedería
si ganaran o perdieran un electrón y cuáles
podrían ser sus configuraciones electrónicas.